(joyful music)
- I was so nervous for some reason.
- Please don't show how much I sweat
without showing how much
they put me through.
I thought I was gonna get here
and lift the bar one time.
That's not what happened, whatsoever.
- I mean, we're extremely strong.
We're animals, right?
- Strong chicken legs. (laughs)
- Cluck cluck.
(laughter)
(clucking chickens)
- Really quickly, what do you guys do,
on the day to day,
to stay healthy and work out?
- I'm really into supplements.
and I like spirulina blue-green algae,
but I just go to 24 hour
fitness. I don't anything crazy.
- I am a PhD student and
a professional sprinter.
- I'm like, "Go over there."
- (laughter)
- But, there's like a big
difference I feel like,
between lifting for sprinting.
And then it sounds like
a lot of y'all, like,
lift for lifting and I...
- Is lifting like a regular
part of your training?
- Yeah, we lift like two
to three days a week.
- That counts.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- More than me.
- I have a cerebral palsy, yeah.
So, I run for the US Paralympics.
For so long, I shied away
from things that I thought
would be too hard
because of my disability,
but then, the more that I
got into running and lifting,
the more I was like, "No,"
like, "I can do these things,
Just as well as everyone else."
- What about you?
- I've been lifting for about
10 years, but I would say,
between 2012 and 2016,
that's when I was really intense about it.
But nowadays, I could
work out six days a week.
Sometimes, I don't work out at all.
- Well, because of your history,
I feel like you should go...
- I know.
- So, we can just...
- Shift down this way.
I'll just go down here.
- Please, please.
- Okay, I feel like I
should at least be right...
- After the sprinter.
- No
(laughter)
- And, you lift come up here.
- Okay, hold on.
(giggling)
- Yeah, I feel like, EMTs have
to be able to lift people.
- That's right, that's right.
- Okay.
We do have the fire
department, so, I always say,
"Lift with your fire
department, not your backs."
but I will say...
yeah, I think I... I check...
I think I do 10,000 steps per shift.
I work 911 in Albuquerque.
We're a pretty busy system.
And I have had to pick
up people off the ground.
Where it's just me and my partner.
But look, look, look guys, guys....
Listen, okay.
There's adrenaline involved, you know?
But, right now, I'm here and sweaty,
so I don't really think it's
going to the same scenario.
- I'm so sweaty. We haven't
started lifting yet.
- Do you kinda, wanna...
Give a little description
on how we started lifting?
- I'll go first, so I
don't lift whatsoever.
I actually... I do exercise though.
I do boxing and I go...
(excited chattering)
But, that has nothing to
do with weight training.
Which is why, I feel, I
should be more this way.
- Okay, okay.
- Still strong though.
- I feel like you have that explosiveness.
- I know.
(understanding mumbles)
- A little pump, here and there.
- I got into lifting when
I started doing track.
I randomly started in two
of the weirdest events.
Pole vault and javelin in high school.
And the guy who coached both those events
he had this program
called, "Six Week Freak."
Where between the...
- That's kinda nasty.
Right? I was like, "Damn, we are 16!"
- Like a Meg Thee Stallion song. (giggles)
- But, it was like a six
week program where we focused
on like three main Olympic lifts.
And I was like, "Oh, this is so cool,
it's easy to set very specific goals."
And like, you can watch
yourself achieve them.
And I think, also there's
a really good community
of non-binary and fem people who lift,
who are really focused on reclaiming,
not just body positivity,
but body neutrality
and being like,
"This is my body, and
it does things for me."
And, that's awesome.
- I got into lifting after I
came back home from college.
All my friends were working out at a gym,
at Crunch like, "Oh, we're gonna do that.
'Cause I have all this time now."
And then, I still continue to lift
because my job requires it.
And, also, because I feel more
empowered and independent.
- So I started lifting...
Well, I was always... Grew up athletic.
I played basketball and sports,
but when I got into college
I kind of started going down a dark path
and I was starting to
have an eating disorder,
to the point where I was eating
one meal a day and then... Sorry.
I don't wanna get emotional.
- That's okay.
- It got to the point where I was like,
even like bulimic, but
weight lifting has...
Sorry, I'm nervous.
- You can deep breath.
- It's okay. it's very emotional
to talk about these things.
Yeah, 'cause I don't talk
about this with anybody.
But, weightlifting has
given me a positive outlet,
for me to take care of my
body in a positive way.
'Cause it's hard being a girl
and just every aspect of your life
is just predicated on how you look.
- Yeah.
- Like pretty privilege is a thing.
So, yeah...
(supportive chatter)
I was really nervous to say that.
- Thank you.
- Thank you guys for being so supportive.
I didn't think I would get
that nervous talking about it.
- How about you guys?
- So I was one of those people
that walked the mile in PE.
- Yes.
- But, it wasn't until the summer
of my senior year of high
school where a friend
of mine, who is really
getting into lifting,
brought a group of us over to the gym.
And I remember I was having trouble
with just the bar, and
just the bar is 45 pounds.
Now here I am, 10 years later.
Power-lifting has opened so many doors
for me where now I'm
learning snowboarding,
Muay Thai, and backpacking.
- I'm like, "I'm scared!"
(nervous chatter)
- You're gonna have to come
this way. Let's go over here.
- No, no, no.
- You gotta go over here.
I just like learning these things,
it doesn't mean I'm good at it.
- And your body's able to
do it cause you're strong.
- Yeah.
- For me, it's kind of...
more of a sad start.
My ex-boyfriend beat me
to death when I was 20...
I was like 20, 21.
I think, I just blocked it out.
I was like 20, instead
of like running away
from things that scare me,
like getting hit, and all that stuff,
and being cornered by men, it was like
"If anyone's gonna hit me,
it's gonna be on my own terms."
Right? And, so it kind of went
from that, started lifting.
I was like, "I'm actually kind of strong."
- You're a bad (beep), dude.
(supportive chatter)
- You should be up here.
- I think I'm the middle.
I'm gonna humbly fit right
down in the middle, for now.
- Now I have one question which would be,
raise your hand, how many of
you have lifted competitively?
Just you?
Okay. Oh India.
I feel like you gotta go this way.
- All right.
- But, that means you
gotta, you gotta move, too.
- That way, yeah.
- No, I think... I think this.
- I don't know.
- You're like a PhD student,
who outruns other humans.
- Professional! Yes.
- No, well we've been tapering,
so I've not lifted in like a month.
- I'm gonna... I just... I really...
I really believe.
- Okay. You've worked
your way back down there.
(laughter)
I dunno how I feel about that.
(evil cackling)
- Yeah. Let's lock it in.
- This is our...
- Have you done a deadlift before?
- Not seriously.
- Not seriously? Okay.
- Hold on.
- You go closer.
- All right.
- So yeah, I would just go hips
width apart, just to start, first.
- Okay.
- Okay
- It's gonna be a little harder
'cause the bar is not
raised by the weight.
- Okay. There you go.
- Keep the weight in your heels, too.
- Yeah.
- There you go.
- That looks pretty good!
(encouraging chatter)
- I've been pretending this
entire time. (sarcastically)
- Do you wanna do 185?
- You okay with that?
- Let's do it!
- I like this! She's like, "Let's do it!"
- Now guys. I'm game.
- She's got a secret, actually.
- Okay, we've gotta hype
her up properly then.
- Really good.
- Oh my God.
- Let's go girl!
- I'm hazing.
- Let's go.
- I believe in you!
- Remember, drag it up.
Push through your feet.
- Yeah, there you go.
- Let's go, let's go.
- Stay tight.
- There we go. You got this.
(excited cheering)
- I love it.
- You didn't even flinch!
(excited chatter)
- Yeah! You did pretty freaking good!
- I thought I was gonna lift it once,
and that was gonna be it.
- Do you have enough chalk on your hands?
- Go closer, closer.
(energetic music)
- You got this!
Perfect.
You got it. Let's go.
- Plant those feet. You got it.
(proud cheering)
(bell dings)
(applause)
- Bre, I'm so proud of her!
- Like I can't believe
she never lifted before.
- I hope this like inspires
her to like try it out.
- It was invigorating.
I will say.
And I think I would try it again.
I'm not crying.
There's sweat in my eyes.
(laughter)
- Yeah, you got this!
- Let's go, let's go! Big breath.
- Hey, come on, you got it!
- You got it.
(encouraging cheers)
(proud cheering)
(bell dings)
- You frigging did it! Oh my God!
- That's a PR?
(applause)
- Holy cow!
- That's so cool.
- That's a lot of weight.
- I don't even know if
I can do that, honestly.
I think I'd have to either...
I'm gonna try this, but if not
I'm gonna have to take five off.
Okay.
- What are you listening to?
- Death metal.
(heavy metal music)
- Go right here.
Big breath, big breath.
- You got it, you got it, you got it.
(excited cheering)
(buzzer rings)
- So close!
- I felt that! It's going, then it's not!
I'm gonna go a little lighter.
- So close!
- All right.
Lightweight.
- I hope so.
Just seeing those weights on,
just seeing them racket and
just like, "Okay, here we go."
(heavy metal music)
(excited cheering)
- Good job!
(bell dings)
- I didn't think I was
gonna do that today!
- I'm liking this.
We all hella strong.
(upbeat music)
- Okay, let's do it!
(excited cheering)
(bell dings)
- Beautiful.
(upbeat music)
(encouraging cheers)
(bell dings)
- Girl, I feel like you
needed silence in that one.
- I think it's really cool
to see people who are smaller
than me lift a lot more than me.
And I feel like that's a misconception
a lot of people might have.
- It's time.
(energetic music)
(encouraging chatter)
- Lock in, stay tight.
Would this be a PR for you or...?
- Yes.
- Cool.
- Oh, dang. Okay.
Let's go. Let's go.
(applause)
- You got this.
This is your turn, now.
(encouraging cheers)
(buzzer rings)
- I felt that.
- Do you wanna try again, or...?
- I think I'm good.
- You got this!
(encouraging chanting)
- I'm like internally screaming.
(applause)
- I'll like look at
the plates and be like,
"Oh gosh, that looks intimidating."
But, with everyone cheering,
it kind of drowns that out.
(encouraging cheers)
- Come on, plant those feet. You got this!
(excited cheering)
(bell dings)
(excited chatter)
- I was like, "Oh my Lord!"
- You did it! You did it.
- Being able to see how,
when a community comes together
to encourage one another,
it does produce really good results.
- That's 315 right there.
- That's crazy.
- That was crazy.
- It was a slow and graceful fall.
- Yeah.
- It was like...
- That looked good, though
- That looked amazing.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Now, I'll get it next time,
and I'll get it cleaner.
- What was your personal record?
- Oh, it was 295.
It was 295, before.
- It was a struggle of a 295.
So, I was very surprised to
see, when I did 295 today.
It just ripped-off before.
I feel like everyone should lift.
It's such a great foundation.
You're gonna feel good about yourself.
You're gonna meet great people at the gym.
And, also it's nice to see
what your body's capable of doing.
- Yeah. Weightlifting rocks. (chuckles)
- [Host] Do you have any final thoughts?
- I'm really excited to take a shower.
- Overall, it was a great group
of women and a great experience.
- People underestimate
women, probably a lot more
than they should and women are stronger
and more capable than
a lot of people think.